I think I'm having my first hot flash
Drew Barrymore telling it like it is
it's gonna be real talk during a recent
interview with Powell's Jennifer Aniston
and Adam Sandler she experiences what
could have been her very first hot flash
I think I'm having one of my first
perimenopause hot flashes for the first
time I think I'm having my first hot
flash
luckily Drew had Jen and Adam there to
hold her hand through it all I feel so
honored
I'm so sorry I think I find do you feel
this
internal heat or maybe I'm just that
excited I think you're that excited it's
a warm hand yeah yeah you got a hot hand
that's good because if it was cold that
would be worry sad
[Laughter]
this
this real a lot of my life has been an
open book but let that be a Liberation
earlier this month the talk show host
gave a glimpse into her messy yet
relatable bedroom show me your room
before and after you clean it I'll go
first everything is kind of all over the
place and super messy but by the end of
the clip she transformed the Clutter
into a spotless space ah
much better
I am trying to find the balance between
hoarder and minimalist yeah Drew showing
fans that stars they're just like us so
relatable meanwhile her child Jennifer
and Adam went beyond a hot flash
discovery
who might be cooking up a reboot we did
come up with a little bit of an idea the
other day about what a trio movie could
be oh Three's Company
that would be fun man that'd be
incredible until then fans of the
recurring Drew and Adam collab can get
excited
liked it
the pair told ET last week they're
working hard to find the perfect script
just said it this morning to each other
I saw her in a hotel and when we make a
movie together every day is beautiful I
think that is important for us like to
hook into it
we not be redundant of something we've
done in the past but not try to prove
we're doing something different just to
prove it it's like an Alchemy you know
Adam and I seem to really know it when
we know it
um and we're like this is it we always
try to you know Infuse something that we
really think is Meaningful as far as
like story lines or what we relate to or
what we want to see in a story because
we need that
[Music]
thank you